yo
everyone what's up
i'm with tristan tyler blake
we are in costa rica
we have just finished up
some of our own explorations
that we've been doing and
we have now merged
with one another for our explorations
together
we are looking at land in costa rica
to build regenerative community on
that includes science spirituality
engineering art
music music that's perfectly said at the
same time i love
and of course
yeah and tristan's been on the show
several times
and i'm super pumped
to be sharing with you guys what we're
currently talking about
in the car ride which is that the
beautiful way to
explain the nature of reality
simply through
infinity and infinity
ultimately they are one we create the
juxtaposition
to
shed light on our true nature
and so i'll lay out a little bit of a
foundation and then we'll have tristan
hit the tennis ball back and we'll
keep chatting about it so
in many ways infinity
can be thought of as
the study
of form the study
of matter the study of
as we can play with this analogy the
be salad out of all possibilities of
food
this is a beet salad
so finity is the study of the beet
salad that we're currently tasting
awareness is currently
experiencing a beet salad
now to juxtapose that with infinity
now infinity is all possible
food so that's there's chicken soup in
there
there's steak dinner there's lettuce
wraps there's all the possibility space
of food
so our true nature is infinity
which is the absolute the highest
which endlessly expresses itself as
these different food options like this
earth
right now is a beet salad and then it
uses
awareness as the observational agent
to experience that beet salad
so we'll go ahead and hit the tennis
ball over to tristan
and see how he feels about this so yeah
throw the beat
over to me the beat uh yeah
um russians actually have a very we love
beets
we love beets yeah so apparently now our
philosophies are like converging on our
uh
leading edges yeah um so
well i'm very interested in what exactly
uh you know out of all the possibility
space
of you know different what are these
actual salads and uh
food forms like what are they metamorph
metamorphoses what are these uh
metaphors for
right what do what do they actually uh
consist of when you
so you jump into one of them so let's
just jump out of the beat salad that
we're currently in which is
costa rica and the world and all of its
uh
inhabitants history and stories and
cultures
all that stuff right because there's no
reason why
you know uh napoleon didn't win
in that battle and then history would
have been different i mean these are
very
kind of um ephemeral little uh
uh changes that they transform
the rest of history and push it into a
new you know there might not have been
uh
the soviet union uh or or you know
these other superpowers growing just
because the initial conditions would
have been changed
so you want to leap us over into chicken
seed yes
what does chicken soup look like yes i'm
very curious so
all right why was walt disney
so obsessed with imagination
why is imagineering such an important
word
why is it so important to take oneself
outside of the beet salad to imagine
what chicken soup looks like because
then one becomes
more and more familiar experientially
with infinity so in this case it would
be something like
the exploration of
other math and physics it would be the
exploration
of other vehicles for awareness
these vehicles have four limbs they have
two
eyes they have
dna encoding
carbon based and they're beautiful
they're incredible vehicles but they're
only
one in the possibility space
of vehicles and
the universe itself this one
song this beat salad
is one exploration
of a specific style of mathematics
and physics that is unfolding
for this awareness to taste
the beet salad yeah that's uh yeah
that's a very interesting
uh deep throat uh
so i've you know i just started studying
mathematics
from ground up so um i actually want to
get to the bottom of it
um the question is is the mathematics we
use created
or is it kind of something we're
discovering and
you know is it hidden in iraq and are we
just scraping it away little by little
and kind of discovering the universal
uh vocabulary of the you know of a form
of matter
both and i'll share why okay so
we are the creators
of the beat salad experience so we
ourselves
wrote the mathematics into place from
the beginning
from the big bang from the automata
that then turned into a
human civilization secreting from a
planet called
earth and
it's also discovered by the human
civilization that secretes from the
planet earth that then recognizes
so recognize but recognize
so we remember
the math that we programmed initially
okay so we programmed this math
initially uh can you
can you explain that a little bit a
little bit more so uh kind of uh
from what state are we talking about uh
um and i'm really hearing
something interesting like a super
organism
sort of that made some decision earlier
and we're simply
piecing together this larger puzzle of
its wish
so super organism you know except we
are the ones that made the wish so
rather than
externalizing it to some other
yeah it is actually us we are the
absolute
that wanted to experience and explore
itself as a beet salad to taste the beet
salad of experience
and that's what this universe one song
is the beet salad yeah i get this
intuition that uh so i
i'm thinking right now about uh you know
where to have lunch
and my neurons are processing and doing
lots of uh
you know a networky things to
help me make that decision and so if you
were to ask the neuron individually kind
of what's your
what's your particular role in that
calculation like uh you
what's your actual you know goal
in that neural network and what are you
solving and i think we're trying to
look just as neurons for some
as you say larger source right so we are
the neurons that are sort of processing
and
we don't actually have the final answer
of what the thought
was that we're all
processing on behalf of but we life is
solving
a computational problem and uh
i think it would be interesting to know
what what what that actual
larger decision was so my decision is to
look for lunch
what is this other the decision was
computational requests
the the request was for us to taste
a beet salad and we are tasting
the beet salad through our experience
yeah okay can we can we send uh
information
back up the um higher order
we are so we are that
which is the
artificial intelligence we are that
which is
the machine learning we are that which
actually takes in
the data or the input of what a beet
salad
tastes like in experience of this rock
orbiting the star with the sensor or the
receptor
or the receptor were the sensor yeah and
so endlessly
we will continue exploring
what all of the other
tastes
of different foods are like
or just experiences so so foods being
kind of a
a way to just uh use a metaphor to
describe
use a metaphor so so and and so this
metaphor is describing because i
really want to get to the bottom of what
it's actually i'll give you another
imagination example so when you
create a vehicle for awareness in a
different
universe a different one song a
different taste
you want to taste chicken soup in that
universe
you may create
a vehicle for awareness that does not
have
eyes and a nose and it has
photoreceptors but of a different like
skin
you know on their skin or something yeah
it will have a completely different
sensory apparatus a different perceptual
apparatus the eye evolved many many
times
intuitive apparatus so so there's the
eye
that evolved you know uh uh just
in separate just in separate ways like
the octopus eye and the human eye are
from completely different uh origins
um so what are these other sensory um
things that you're imaginings right so
we have a couple and
not we're not talking about the five
senses that uh
you know that are kind of typically
associated because there's thousands of
sensors all across your body you know
heat temperature sensors here's another
one stretch your imagination
outside of what a design
looks like where it's no longer
three dimensions with
another dimension of time so
you can go from three one three space
one time to
what it's like to have three space and
two time or two space in two time
there's all of these different
arrangements
to explore
that we are just one experiencing
we're experiencing just one
which is the beet salad can you explain
these dimensions uh a little bit because
so i have a mathematical so
understanding what that is
it would be something it would be
something like uh
so i know there's x y and let's say z
yeah and then if we
instead of having one dimension of time
imagine if rather than having just one
clock
if we had two clocks two dimensions of
time okay
so you have two clocks one clock is like
the current civilizational clock that
we're using right now
and then another clock is something that
you've never
imagined before it's something that's
wildly
beautiful and eccentric maybe something
like a
if you're planning to meet with somebody
you're meeting with them
at 12 o'clock on the left wrist watch
but also six o'clock on the right wrist
watch
but somebody else is meeting with
someone else at 12 o'clock on the left
wrist watch
and three o'clock on the right wrist
watch i think time
has uh some relationship with like uh
physics and quantum total mechanics like
so so
from what i understand you know let's
just say you fly next to a black hole
um it's pull on you uh will
deviate your time your actual um
the actual amount of time that is
passing because it's kind of related to
the
like curve of space time so
so the space and time seem to have a
relationship and i think gravity plays
a role in that so to have two different
wrist watches you
you just have to have arms that are
long enough to um
you know be gravitated towards like some
kind of black hole or something like
that
and then yeah i'm sure you can't have
two you you need an arm
pointing at a different black hole
basically
yeah time is very interesting um it's
particularly
directions of time that are possible
i think actually going forward in this
uh in the next few years
um some of the physics that's coming out
right now
um is going to be dealing with uh with
sense and gravity and
uh with being able to well try to
measure it i mean i mean
apparently you know in order to pick up
on gravitons or these little like uh
subatomic particles of of gravity
you would need a particle accelerator
that reaches from the sun
to jupiter or something like that so
it's so
small each unit that uh to detect it
would require a massive amount of energy
way more than than we have so in general
what we're trying to describe
through this podcast conversation is
that
the analysis of the beet salad
is fantastic and it's beautiful but
it's even more important than the
analysis of the beet
salad is to recognize that one's true
nature
is the infinite combinations of
food that are explored endlessly
and that way we are not
blinded by the illusion that all there
is is just the beet salad
so what else is there uh so so i like
uh you know um i'm a lot more into the
kind of the finite space
in that example i really love kind of
using
the principles that are available
particularly in the scientific method
to achieve or derive um experimental
kind of like
demonstrable results you know that are
repeatable
um in the infinite space what's there
that is for example and like what's
there that
is not available in the physical
material
realm all of the possibilities
in the finite you have the beet salad
and it's fantastic and it tastes great
but it's just the beet salad i don't
can we you know this metaphor it's very
valuable and useful
but i would like to uh use a more um
kind of concrete term of actually
something that i'm familiar
i don't even eat that many beats here
here's here's a way to here's another
way to say it
is that this earth is one way to paint a
blank canvas
okay you have endless ways to paint a
blank canvas and that you've
become associated that most people
alive on the planet have become
associated
with themselves as the one
painting that is the planet earth rather
than the blank canvas that is eternally
painted in all infinite possibility
so another example is the music
so earth is one combination
of musical notes pieced together into a
song it's a very beautiful song we all
adore it very much
lots of people do some people don't
and when you
piece when you explore the possibility
space of piecing together
all different combinations of musical
notes into songs
you will never come to the end of that
and so that is your true nature
is the one that eternally listens
and experiences the songs
you have just become accustomed to
listening to
only one song planet earth and you think
that your true nature is only living
in the body in planet earth
but your true nature is both that
and the infinite but one must go
to the infinite first and begin
associating themselves
with that and then they can properly
integrate being the beet salad
or being the song or being this
coloration on a blade canvas
properly because they know themselves as
the blank canvas they know themselves
as the endless possibility of all the
possible
combinations of musical notes so this is
a conversation about free will
and recognizing your uh
the freedom of that free will kind of
like the space of
free decisions that you have potentially
and and maximizing on that and then from
there deciding what's the best
sort of decision based on all of the
range of possibilities right
i kind of see this as a like i've been
thinking about a lot a lot about free
will recently
and i've been shaken by the idea that
these bacteria control our
behaviors and decisions and
and they're finding more and more
parasites that are able to
influence our thoughts and our uh
kind of our desires our goals and we
just like we
are being influenced by hundreds of
billions of organisms
so and we are not a single one like i'm
not a single guy
there's many many many things taking
place to keep me
here and many bacteria that i'm very
grateful for
um and so transitioning to this view of
the world of be
being a cloud of information or cloud of
life and then interacting with other
clouds
is definitely very um a very valuable
sort of uh
frame to look from in order to
appreciate
uh life in general and just life's kind
of uh
beautiful complexity
you know so free but free will has
shaken uh i've been shaken because
these things that control our behaviors
like
what percentage of our free will is
available for
quote unquote the uh you know the
individual
the the tristan there to make versus the
bacterial decision
the viral probably decision the
um actual kind of unconscious decision
that was already made
the chemical decisions you know the
hormonal and stuff
like how what percentage do you think of
the full spectrum of choices
is is the decision
available to to me versus other forces
yeah it's a super exciting
question yet at the same time we can
also
come up with the answer where is the
line of separation
between you and the thousand species of
good bacteria that live inside of you
and the answer is there is no line of
separation it's one
symbiotic mind-body spirit
complex unit and that
it's harmonized together as a cohesive
whole and that there is
clearly very clearly
a beautiful
genetic expression that happens from
the thousand species of gut bacteria
which each have about 2 000 or so
genetic
expressions so you've got about two
million
genetic expressions that are happening
from gut bacteria and then you have
about 20 000 human gene expressions
so you have about a hundred x more
bacterial gene expressions happening so
you could potentially say that there's a
lot of
dominating power that's coming from the
bacterial forces
and yet at the same time there's a lot
of
will and choice and prefrontal control
also
executive functioning that's coming
coming from
the units
ability to
make a divine alignment towards
a north star towards a noble aim towards
something that is
transcendent and not something that's
just
limbic not something that's just primal
instant gratification
fosters lethargy and gluttony
whereas delayed gratification that more
top down prefrontal control
using will or choice to pursue something
that's noble or
transcendent that's delayed
gratification
and that provides a lot more love
light meaning purpose
fulfillment peace joy
abundance well-being prosperity
flourishing
those things are a product of one's
ability
to delay their gratification walter
michelle and the marshmallow experiment
are probably one of the most important
experiments that's ever been done
and really boiling down to simply
delaying gratification more prefrontal
and less limbic
they should have used chocolate rather
than uh marshmallow like i don't
know you know like i i really think that
the because i've recently been dancing
with cacao trees
uh i went down this little journey where
we're going actually uh
we're i think we're gonna meet more
cacao trees these are very special
plants
and uh so cacao brought me there you
know the
the chocolate like i always wanted to
know the origin of my um
just passion for chocolate i eat at
least three times a day
and uh so so i've been thinking about
the marshmallow test and it's like
yeah i bet the chocolate results like if
we can redo the experiment but with
chocolate
what kind of results would you get
like would people be able to if there
was like a ferraro rocher
sitting there how likely are people to
pass the test
do you still have any chocolate left
from the previous uh no
we will pick some more up though
let's uh it's still recording right yes
and let's
let's wrap well let's just tell them a
little bit about the
trip you know kind of like give them
some insight into where we'll go
let's do it so we were just at
we were in the northwest of costa rica
tristan has been spending a year are you
on your third month
almost here yeah yeah so tristan's on
his third month in costa rica i'm on my
second week in costa rica
and
it's been good this place is delivered
costa rica is basically
one of the hubs
for planetary enlightenment it's going
to become
one of the hubs for it it already is
becoming it very quickly
for planetary engineering planetary
science
planetary awakening all of those coming
together
and
we spent some time near the volcano
miravares today
at a volcanic lodge that was fantastic
in the central part of costa rica we are
now driving down to
a late lunch meeting that we are having
in la fortuna where we are further
exploring the land purchase
options and micro climates and
geographies then we are heading to the
east coast towards limon
and exploring some more
over there and we'll be doing this for
about
almost another week and we should
by the end of the year we have the aim
to have secured
a plot of land with our
investor friends that are very excited
in
the community we're building and to have
begun the basic architectures
on the property to enable
anywhere from 10 to 20 people or so to
probably live there
year-round people that are working on
next-generation energy technologies and
much else
3d printing printing farms i want a 3d
printer farm
on a farm and then
about 100 to 200 people capacity
for when we do larger scale
events that kind of a thing
so what we're talking about right now
was shifting
from infinity from only the beet
salad to infinity all
possible combinations of food
that we are endlessly tasting
is a massive part of the pedagogy
that we will be discussing
at the regenerative community
because the utility of it is that
you move away from being a contracted
egoic finite separate entity
that feels like a hairless monkey
on a rock orbiting a star that's
meaningless
and you move away from that contracted
energy
where you're trying to seek peace and
happiness
by extracting it from the beet salad
instead what you do is you recognize
your own
infinite nature you feel an expansion
in your energy you feel a relaxation of
that contraction
you recognize that we all share our same
source
we all share our same awareness and what
we are doing is we are
experiencing a beet salad out of an
infinite possibility of food so we've
been experiencing different food we're
going to keep experiencing
does every person experience uh
different foods like uh
because i kind of i can briefly wrap
just on that point yeah just
because what happens the utility of the
that recognition is that you no longer
have any tendency to commit violence
because you recognize that we share our
source and our awareness
you no longer have malevolence or an
extractive
will from the
others but rather you recognize that we
share our being
in this beet salad and therefore
we maximize our collective
potential harmony prosperity and
abundance
through these recognitions now the
question was something about
do we perceive somewhat
similar in terms of the speed salary
like i'm definitely experiencing
a very um specific experience comparing
of the beat sound you're viewing in a
sense you're viewing
the beat salad can be thought of like a
soccer game
football you're viewing football right
now but you're viewing it from
the you're viewing it from behind
barcelona's goalie
and i'm viewing it from the
the half line of the field
right so we're experiencing barcelona
playing madrid in a soccer game that's
also a beet salad
and you're watching it from behind
barcelona's goalkeeper
which in the second half it's gonna be
madrid's goalkeeper
and i'm watching it from the halfway
line so we're watching the beet salad
and tasting the beet salad we're
watching the soccer game
from two different positions
which is why you're seeing some of the
nuances
around what happens when
the ball madrid is attacking
and is crossing the ball in and trying
to
volley or headed into barcelona's goal
versus you're seeing those nuances i
can't see them as clearly
whereas i'm seeing the nuances near the
half line really clearly
and you're not and so that's the beauty
of having eight billion unique
agents experiencing the beet salad
or the barcelona versus madrid football
match
simultaneously now yeah these metaphors
are
quite challenging to uh for me at least
to
um kind of wrap my head around i sort of
i um
i actually don't play enough football
did you get how there's eight billion
observers yes in the stadium yeah so no
that that's a good
that's good that you got well it's good
that you got that part yeah
um and everyone has their own uh kind of
perspective
on the players and the ball
[Music]
yeah these are all these are all
different uh shots
so um so the the question is kind of
uh yeah is this so every person has
their own experience of
of reality but to and and you're saying
that the
meat salad is the is the actual stadium
yeah so the beet
salad is the game that's being played
and that
the next game that's going to be played
uh
let's say it's played on the well the
next game let's say that's going to be
played
it might not even be it could be
something like
um a world cup match between
let's say uh like argentina and spain
uh it could be that so instead of
barcelona and madrid it's shifted that
or or or or or
it could be instead a different
sport that is played altogether it could
shift to a basketball game well this is
actually a pretty good uh
um condition because
the physics of uh the universe
right they they sort of uh are
the constants only allow like
the field is only built in a certain way
that can play a certain sport like if
you don't have
a basketball court you can't play
basketball
and uh or so and and you can't play
football on a basketball court
you know in in that sense so the
conditions of
this universe mathematically and and the
material science fraud
the big bang until the civilization
enabled
the barcelona versus madrid match
and then only and then what happens is
as we've been talking about with sir
roger penrose and many other of the
world leading physicists
now have cyclic cosmological
understandings that where we're going
is where we came from so as we came from
a big bang we are going towards
endless future big bangs so we're going
to continue
exploring more food options so next up
is chicken soups and steak dinners and
lettuce wraps or in other words
we're gonna play basketball games and
tennis matches and we're gonna go and
golf 18 holes
all this type of stuff so so from what i
understand
and that's going to require different
math and physics from the big bangs
that's going to require different
unfoldings of
the stadiums that enable said sports to
play
from what i've seen in terms of just my
personal research so
and and this could be uh you know
misguided but uh
um right now like that there's uh
cosmological errors
and uh sort of the one that we're in you
know the soliferous
and all of these uh um there's gonna be
a um
like a photo just a what is it like the
photon error i think that's actually
going right now
uh and then it's leading towards this uh
black hole era where matter collapses
and the
you know there's photon decay right so
this universe um
is there's are you telling me there's a
speculation that it's going to
collapse and they'll bounce back is that
sort of are we taking that
um interpretation there's there's a
balance there's two
there's two options that i've found so
far that are most
sort of eloquent in describing this
one of them is sort of this long-term
option that you just described which is
some sort of a big bang to big crunch to
big bang to big crunch to big bang to
big crunch endlessly
and then that's how you experience to be
the salad the chicken soup the steak
dinner etc
and then that's sort of on this like
multi-billion year time scale where
we don't necessarily know how much
longer
we're gonna evolve in this beet salad
before we get to the chicken soup
the next exploration whereas the second
model
that i feel like potentially has a
stronger resonance
is that the same way
that we are currently building
artificial general intelligence and
neurotechnology and biotechnology like
the neural link and we're building out
these indistinguishable virtual
realities
all of those technologies synthesize
together into what's been called the
metaverse
and so what we hypothesize like john
smart with the transcension hypothesis
is that
what we're going to do in the next 50
100 150 200 years is we're going to
build out all of these indistinguishable
virtual realities and we're going to
begin immersing ourselves into them for
80 years at a time
and that that's what the recursion is
so that's the next exploration of
chicken soups and beet salads and
basketball games and tennis matches
you can build your own virtual reality
like experience that's
probably going to be indistinguishable
from this
kind of what we're doing right now like
it will be
won't make a difference if i'm sitting
here and driving or if i'm
in a headset simulating sitting here and
driving right
yeah which is what this already is yeah
well i i don't know that
uh i i think it would be fun to i think
would be great if uh
this was a simulation i think that's a
speculation that
could be possible you're using awareness
to experience the form and identity of
tristan tyler blake
you are awareness that is shared and
eternal and
impersonal experiencing tristan tyler
blake's
meat costume spacesuit and
i'm the impersonal shared awareness the
same as you
same as everybody experiencing the meat
costume spacesuit of atlas
okay so there so we're saying there's
one
sort of uh experiencer and we are the um
like the fingertips of this thing right
yeah like the nerve endings
or the nerve endings or the neurons of
this
thing um and
do we have uh kind of so so
you know i would love to have some
evidence for this or uh some sort of
like kind of like uh
theory or you know where can i where
where would i go to look
because this this it makes sense
you know it feels uh intuitively
interesting and
uh valuable kind of to think about that
way right with the with the bacteria
hundreds of
millions of them let's start with your
direct experience
yeah okay so
are you aware
am i aware of uh are you aware period
are you aware question mark do you yes
of course you exist
okay okay so
do you see how the question am i aware
or i am aware as a statement or
declarative
comes before i am aware of
tristan
the statement i am aware comes before
the statement i am aware of tristan
i don't follow so i am uh so
you ask me are you aware and i sense
awareness beautiful okay and now and now
we're gonna
add attributes okay so now the
attributes that we're adding
are your name we've added your name
the next attribute that we can add is
your ethnicity we can add another
attribute which is your career we can
what if i
actually don't uh i mean i don't like i
say my name but i don't really feel
connected to it oh well then well then
you're actually closer to the
metaphysical truth
which is i am aware is most
upstream before i am aware of tristan
before i am aware i am in costa rica
before i am aware
i am in a car driving is i am
aware before all of the attributes
before
all of the descriptors before all of the
symbolization the semiotics
before all of that is just the statement
i
exist i am aware
simple being itself
yeah so that's a being itself um okay so
now you see
there is almost a pure
bare empty layer
to your awareness that is shared with
mine
because i have the same direct
experience as you do i
am aware first and then i am aware of
atlas
yeah so the way that i uh sort of uh
you know came to this long time ago this
awareness
uh experience right is uh i just felt
like there was a ipad
in front of my face
and then i just i was like what if i was
just to pull
um it away or pull back from it
and see all of the calculations that are
taking place
uh unconsciously right great and so
so and then you you're like you can see
that the body is adding
signals and information to this
stream of information that's coming in
and your body's adding
kind of red over here don't do this do
this fear like all these little things
um so is that what we're talking about
kind of like that awareness that
pulls away from the uh yeah that's yeah
that's a great tablet
yeah that's a great way to put it we've
actually been talking about this
analogy metaphor now for about a hundred
years
in spirituality because of the birth of
motion picture
so as soon as sort of cinema and film
was birthed
we began being able to explain
the metaphor or analogy of the
movie or most recently with the birth of
virtual reality
yeah we began using that yeah yeah
donald hoffman
who we've had on the show has a very
fascinating way of also explaining
that we are mistaking our headset
so we're mistaking infinity our headset
as ultimate reality when in reality it's
just a beet
salad and we're observing the beet salad
through the headset
and so even cutting edge scientists
cognitive scientists like donald hoffman
and his team
are again synthesizing with spirituality
just like
siraj penrose and physics are also
synthesizing with spirituality
so in the movie analogy like you
described a moment ago
the most common way like many
great teachers this is our nisargati
maharaja has been one of our favorites
explain it quite simply like
you are that which is
aware of the movie
of driving in costa rica
you are that which is aware
of driving through costa rica can i
control it i'm curious
and that's where the will and the choice
come in
so i'm gonna make this rain uh go away
how do i make this rain go away
um so so that's one of the upstream
causes of suffering actually
is when people
are arguing with the frames of the movie
so if you have craving for alternate
frames of the movie
or if you have a version if you're
trying to get away from certain frames
of the movie
you're going to create suffering so
they're simultaneously the radical
unconditional acceptance of the movie
frames that come
at the same time that there is a desire
for a transcendent noble aim
in the movie so
i am aware first and then i am aware of
tristan's second
and then i am aware of tristan's north
star third
and so tristan's north star might be
something like
architecting the maximal abundant
prosperous future as a planet possible
and so that is a divine very important
star
and you will absolutely adjust your
movie frames towards that given your
will and choice
towards that versus if you were
lethargic and apathetic
and gluttonous and didn't give a living
[ __ ] about any north star
but but that so that north like why do i
have a north star and some people don't
like what who decides that what's the um
what's the thing that kind of gives
to one and not the other or takes away
from one
you know well where do where do we get
these and why
some over others so if there's an
infinite source
right um i'm curious
why do some have eyes and some have you
know
some are blind so that's kind of a you
know same question about god but just
about the implement source why yeah
yeah it's a beautiful question so
so the first kind of most macro level
answer is that
you are not just aware
of tristan you are also aware
simultaneously
of
all of these units that are experiencing
the beat sound so
the unit that is
currently lacking the desire
for a transcendent noble aim or north
star
you are also them simultaneously as you
are you
and so that is a macro level view of it
and then a sort of secondary view of it
is something like
the importance of having contrast
very similar to how yesterday when we
were driving right now we're currently
driving on a quite smooth
paved road in costa rica and uh
you could probably see a little bit in
the back but yeah yeah
yeah so i'll show you guys quick yeah i
will i'll adjust it
yeah i think it actually should be
it should be the road and then our voice
is like it actually should be
i'll adjust it back afterwards
so um
right now we're driving on this quite
smooth road and yesterday we were
actually driving on a bumpy volcanic
road where we were rocking back and
forth non-stop
and the reason why i bring it up is
because we had an experience of contrast
where we were able to have a deeper
amount
of gratitude and a deeper amount
of recognizing the difference
between being on a road that
is bumpy versus a road that is
smooth and so in a sense
very similarly with our
creativity that we've designed this
reality with
as the beet salad
that we
we have
bush we have some bush right
we have created the contrast in the beet
salad
where we have a similar to the bumpy
road
and smooth road we have those that are
more enlightened
and we have those that are more
egotistical we have those that live
infinity f-i-n-i-t-y
infinity finite live those that
think that they are only the beet salad
and then we have those that are more
enlightened we have those that know
themselves as
infinite we have those that know
themselves as that which eternally
tastes
all possible combinations of food and
this being just one expression of that
and so we need that contrast in order
for this play
to happen for this play to undergo and
that
when we experience chicken soup or
lettuce wrap avocado
affogato affigato what is avocado oh my
god it's um
it's a scoop of vanilla ice cream oh and
then you pour a
um espresso on top of it and then you
eat it
and you know what i like about it at the
moment and then you look at it and then
you stare at
it so yeah the infinite avocado
so yeah this thing um what's what you
know what i like about it the most it's
like um is that italian or is that
actually from
here i i think it's italian it's um
yeah i i we're gonna go to a cafe right
now in la fortuna which uh has
up my i used to i was drinking like
three affigato's a day there
for like a month and a half just that
was my cafe
oh my gosh so yeah uh but vanilla ice
cream vanilla ice cream with a shot of
espresso it's so good and whenever i go
to like restaurants i always look for it
yeah it'd be exciting to
yeah to hit that by the way one of the
locals
tony that we were uh hanging out with a
couple of days ago
ended up communicating to me that
there's this cute little bit of rainfall
that happens between he said
one and two o'clock and it's exactly
like 150 when it rained and so
uh it's kind of funny that costa rican
microclimates
i like this all right that's a wrap i
adore you all so much
we adore you we're super grateful for
you tuning in to
this episode i'm really happy that
we were able to unpack some very explain
like on five understandings of
infinity infinity and also
create a lot of good alchemical
container space for you to
transmute and transform yourself through
these very simple
explain like on five analogies and
metaphors and so do let us know your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode we'd love to hear from you
if the video brought you value give it a
like it helps the youtube algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
and share the video with people you feel
like this would make a positive impact
on
and i'm glad that you guys have also
gotten the update from tristan and i
about
what we're doing here this week and
in terms of what we're creating together
and building the future
i want to take them uh like uh like so
this episode is just about
you know what's on what's on your mind
kind of the uh
finite infinite both of ours and two and
yeah well yeah i mean we have different
uh uh you know different frameworks for
uh observing and understanding these
things yeah we'll explore a lot of other
things including the analysis of form
um yeah science i think there's many
others
of course of course
there's a lot of different uh things to
discuss during this trip
so we will we will we adore you all tell
us what you want us to talk about
actually that's a good point
let us know are you what you want us to
drop that in the comments below yeah
exactly we love you much love talk to
you soon
peace
i'll give them the wi-fi password yeah
exactly
i think we're getting closer